gang that state trashy tour is in high
gear talking overtime oh baby yeah do
yourself a favor grab the squad come out
and see the boys Kippy and I co-headline
doing a little standup comedy then we
play a little areu garbage with the
crowd it's a fun fun time yeah next up
are Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Buffalo New
York and then we added a third show in
Toronto get those tickets and we're
going to Pontiac Michigan fourth show
added in Chicago shout out to it then
Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee Sacramento
second show outed there San Francisco
San Jose Washington DC date rescheduled
and then Philadelphia Pennsylvania added
a second show with the Filmore get those
tickets gang we love you K let's talk
about that mmobile shout out to Mint
mobile boys listen let's not fool each
other inflation is everywhere you need a
little break and mint mobile has got you
covered mint mobile let you order from
home and save a ton of cash with phone
PL starting at 15 bucks a month oh baby
if you order today at mintmobile.com
garbage that's mintmobile.com garbage do
it gang now let's get to the show yeah
welcome welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh yeah
it's that little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find that
at they grp to be classy they just a big
old piece of trash trash trash trash I'm
your host stage holy coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
toties in the new edition I just saw her
dragon in a nitrous tank through the
back door okay going to be a fun weekend
all right my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me Swinging a miss
this week sure he is the CEO of Ru
garbage he's International businessman
and he's my best pal in the whole wide
world and I love him give it up for KJ
Kevin James Ryan everybody what up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are true to R
cooking then obviously see the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com garbag gang check it out
it's a goddamn party over there yes it
is and how about a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones the twos the threes and the fours
he crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone MC scruffs Toby
McMullen everybody what up dude I'm
stoked we got a guy in here talk about
my vibe Hawaiian shirt tattoos this
guy's ready for a pontoon boat afternoon
if you know what I'm saying he looks
like a swinger in Florida dude I love it
I can't tell if you're an ex Navy SEAL
or a bartender in Brooklyn I heard guy's
all over the map baby I love it gang we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest here with us today for the first
time he is a very funny very successful
standup comedian podcaster actor and
producer and you might have seen him in
but not limited to you got the Late Show
with Craig Ferguson you got live at
Gotham he has his own Comedy Central
presents the tonight's show with Conan
O'Brien the tonight's show with Jay Leno
this is not happening the the Playboy
Morning Show 199 episodes of that cha
ching you got the Church of What's
Happening Now The Disappearance of Toby
Blackwood uh he has two amazing podcasts
scared to death and time suck he also
has multiple standup specials and albums
out uh some of the included not limited
to revenge is near crazy with a capital
f here this Chinese affection don't wake
the bear maybe on the problem feel the
heat get out of here devil and he has a
brand new special out right now try to
get better on YouTube which is tearing
up the charts give it up for Dan cumins
everybody man I almost [__] that up
God damn it I don't think I've heard all
the that stuff L I'm like oh yeah I feel
like I'm a thousand years
old he started hitting open mics in
1968 started out at the Roman Coliseum
everybody opening up for the Gladiators
buddy thank you so much for coming in
sitting down for we're super excited
give us the backstory give us the give
us the origin story of Dan cumins the
origin story I I born in rigin Idaho so
atypical uh size town probably for most
comics about 400 people there now [__]
Jesus and and isolate I graduated uh 23
kids in my graduating class and our town
is an hour from a stoplight and well
that's the landmark yeah there's an oak
tree about four clicks away yeah yeah
you're no one's born there unless it's
like you're born at home but it's like
there's a town an hour away that has a
hospital and a stoplight and then
another hour gets you quote unquote a
mall that has like two three or four
stores stores in 7even yeah it's like a
strip mall more than a mall it's like a
three-hour drive to an actual mall or
anything so it's like a very rural were
you born in your house or at a hospital
no we made it we they they made it to
the hospital so traffic was light that
day but it is crazy like my grandpa only
one light yeah you're cruising my mom
has one sister and my grandpa delivered
her so it's like they couldn't make it
in time and then how tough people are
they made it most most of the way and
then my grandma uh after giving birth
drove them the rest of the way while my
grandpa in the past held the baby that
just came out of her and they made it to
the rest of the way to the hospital
that's [__] that's Pioneer [__] dude
that's all right it's a little logging
town just in the middle of Idaho that's
what it's a logging Town yeah used to be
logging Town Sawmill burn down uh did I
mean classic a country song like Bruce
Springsteen or something you know yeah
the problem is the firefighters are 2
hours
[Laughter]
exactly it is a crazy thing where you I
do think about like if I fall down and
get hurt here oh like my odds of making
it you know safely to a hosit or so much
lower there's not a local doctor or
anything like that no uh no doctors
there's like no white collar anybody in
town it's all just home like it's just
like now it's white waterer rafting in
the summer okay it's like some ra it's
on this Salmon River and it's just like
you know somebody works at the grocery
store and there's the post office and
damn I I guess maybe now you could work
remote they only got like high-speed um
uh as far as like tele like 5G type a
couple years ago so it's like everything
is way behind still doing dialup jeez
when I was growing up I mean no radio
stations no cable none of that stuff
made it you know internet was a decade
plus late getting there it's it's really
is what did your parents do my dad was a
logger and then con Carpenter most of
the men in my family worked at The
Sawmill before it was done okay and then
my and then after that was done uh my my
dad moved to Alaska for construction we
moved up a little bit my mom and I with
him sister was pu people holy [__] God
damn first guest born on the Oregon
Trail God damn if Riggins wasn't hard
enough they moved to
Alaska it is let's go somewhere easier
how many members of your family died
from the
fever damn damn you dis Terry you got
another but yeah couldn't get a lime
anywhere uh and then when I was was um
third grade my parents split up Dad
stayed up in Alaska for a while work in
construction mom came back we moved back
here with my grandparents uh that time
my grandpa's doing odd jobs back to
where back to the rins yeah little tiny
Town back to the big city back to the
big city yeah my grandpa was doing like
odd construction jobs and he built
little rental properties and had that
and then my grandma worked at the post
office uh which is so funny to town like
that that's like the premier job that's
it you have a government job govern
that's good Benny you got Benny the know
of everybody's business s what who's
getting packages yeah so we live with my
grandparents for a little while then
moved uh my mom sister and I moved uh to
one of the rentals okay and then I
stayed in Riggins now from you know
third grade we moved on as like two or
three to Alaska and then third grade to
eighth grade still in Riggins and then
ninth uh so freshman sophomore year high
school my dad was now living in Las
Vegas and I moved down to uh live with
him for two years okay and then Rand rly
he moved back to the same area but
outside of rigan so now my junior senior
high school and I had no driver's
license my junior I was I was living
about 15 miles outside of this little
town essentially uh my wife uh cracks up
like uh when she saw like I I took her
to the place I lived in what it really
isct it in my head my mother-in-law
cried when she saw she she's like how
did you come out of this dude I'm
wondering uh this house where I lived in
my fresh or uh junior senior of high
school it was like a tiny I don't know a
th000 square foot one bedroom one bath
little house and then there was this
extension basically a shed it was just
like no insulation concrete floor roof
and everything but no amenities at all
and that was where my bedroom was so I
essentially was in a shed yeah you
camped out for high school camp out I
camped out junior senior of high school
who was in the main house your mom dad
and stepmom dad and step dad and stepmom
what happened to your sister uh sister
stayed living with my mom and so okay
and so then I would kind of like uh
bounce you know like weekends or
whatever yeah yeah but in this along
this kind of rural Canyon and then yeah
just who had a better house at the time
where did you like being cuz that was
always big mom or dad's where did you
like being I was stubborn you had the
heat on I know Jesus Christ no I should
I should have went with Mom I was a
stubborn kid and I made this decision to
go live with my dad my dad way worse off
my mom yeah it sounds he's he's not even
in rigin dude and then I felt stupid
kind of like like ad that like maybe I
should have stayed and so I kind of
gutted it out with that but like mom's
place was better um in the term of which
is crazy like the scale of things my mom
lived in a manua like a trailer okay but
it was like a a nice trailer sure so
like that would have been that would
have been that's like the Ritz compared
to where you were double wide what are
we talking double wide nice yep and and
like on uh a different foundation so
there was kind of like a basement like
they put it on oh a concrete so pretty
fancy [__] killing it out therey
fancy you're quickly becoming my
favorite person I'm trying to pick was
there was there a main drag in the town
like a Main Street the highway it's
Highway
95 right by the call box but it slows it
slows down to 25 miles per hour sure and
it it was so funny you would do some of
the things that like kids in cities
would like you know like uh cruise up
and down the street but it literally
there's only the highway is what goes
from one end to town to the other
there's no side streets it's a narrow
Steep Canyon on these these big
mountains down to this River and so we
would just like drive up and down
bumping our stereos mhm and it's like a
it's like a one mile back and forth
trolling for chicks yeah you're passing
like you know the you're ping your mom
yeah there's 10 girls in your class like
you know all of them you're you're
meeting no one knew ever sure you're not
impressing anybody what was freshman
year in Vegas like oh cult shock yeah my
class I remember it had 600 roughly 650
people that's a big CL that's a big CL a
big school and it was kind of rough we
had like rumors of like Bloods and CPS
you know like kids at this Bonanza High
School at the time and I would see like
these crazy brawls and stuff it was just
so foreign you're walking around in a
loin cloth and a [__] ax on you holy
[__] dude it was like the classic it was
like a movie like fish out of water F
out of water it's like let's put the
country boy in
Vegas crazy why don't you try like
Toledo or something ease into it and I
became such a delinquent
I just like didn't fit in with like the
kids in class I mean they they I was
weird like I you know like didn't know
how to dress with the cool clothes I
looked like a country bumpkin yeah where
would you go shopping when you were in
rig where was like where were you
getting your clothes uh Kmart or like
Shopco like two hours away two hours
hair of dungar or or I would call it
like um truck stop fashion like gas
station has some T-shirts oh yeah I had
like it's cool now but I un ironically
you're not cool was wearing like the
wolves howling at the moon shirt sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah my coolest my
coolest piece of clothing for years was
I had a jean jacket that had a Native
American Chief headdress uh silk
screened onto the back it could be 105
degrees You're Still rocking walk tell
me nothing baby sounds pretty
sweet it was like Wolverine's like Red
Dawn smaller um okay damn any sports
growing up uh were there sports in the
there was an all this but we didn't have
like a baseball team who would they who
would play who we had they would wrestle
wolves in
stad wrest wolves what was the other
closest school half an hour away was a
equally small town all right and then
another you know 40 minutes from that
was another there was like a bunch of
these old little logging towns along the
highway was there a football team
eight-man football eight-man football
what's crazy is one of the members of
the Dallas Cowboys right now Leighton
vanderesh came out of rigin Idaho played
eight-man football walked on to boisee
State and then rafted and has been
killing it for the Cowboys but that's
the only story like thatuh would you
hunt and stuff like that and fish when
you were a kid yep yep fish and Hunt
yeah like Deer uh and then actually on
the special I tell just just because it
makes people so sad uh to hear this
hunting story but I had like a classic
like killing Bambi's father in front of
Bambi hunting story and to me it's like
you just grow up hunting it's like
whatever it's what it is people lose
their [__] mind with hunting they
like like it cracks me up when there's
who eats meat yeah I'm like dude you eat
you eat meat you have to know where it
comes from yeah yeah if you're not
willing to kill it yeah would you would
you eat a lot of the stuff you killed I
presume or yeah yeah yeah so um yeah
some sure that meat freezer was stocked
yeah my mom has yet the the classic kind
big deep freeze in the in the shed where
you know you store up a crazy amount of
you know whatever venison or whatever uh
would she hunt like your sister were
they do it no they didn't actually like
the taste of deer so more like beef and
stuff okay but like my Grandpa would you
know took me hunting and then fishing I
would just like have to make it's funny
nobody really liked that either my
Grandpa and Grandma were so poor when
they were young they fished all the time
like for part of their food and then
hated fish as they got older but I would
do that and then it's this sounds pretty
barbaric and it is kind of but people
would just kill like groundhogs and
squirrels just for the [__] of it like
like I got cable what are you supposed
to do I have someone's got to go I I
have I have so many
memories you can't wash mashing again
what do we to get there and do something
I just remember like being out in a
field like the woods and they would just
find where like these groundhogs were
and it would just be like that would be
the weekend focal point you would Camp
you know drink beer around the campfire
at night and then during the day it's
just dudes drinking keystones blasting
any creature that dares to pop its head
out into the open they wouldn't eat him
or anything like that just little
groundhogs I know I know they are so
cute but it was just like I don't know
I'm with it I I mean come on we already
drove up and down to town three times
what do you want us to do natural
Predators I've never been I've never
been able to ask you on this this is
very exciting do you know anyone who's
competed on like the ESPN2 like
Lumberjack games no but like people
didn't get it was more like functional
like they did it for their livelihood
but there wasn't a sport version of it
but I've watched those and I'm like
thought of people that I grew up with
I'm like oh Dave Buchanon would have
killed this R shout out to
Davey Randy schwift is a great childhood
name when you said your dad was a logger
what does that exactly entail he was I
mean there's different you know like I
guess what do you call it like positions
within that he was a Faller I think they
tend to call it uh which was the guy who
goes and actually just cuts down the
tree and then they have it's got It's
been so many years he but I think it's
called the skitter it's like this big
piece of equipment where they have these
cables that they can throw down hill
love that show American logger oh I D
he's doing that kind of [__] yeah when
he was young like now he's done
construction for years but like when he
was young that's what he was doing and
there are yanked them up M and it's
dangerous dangerous as [__] no [__]
Hospital anywhere either dude there was
that guy Randy Swift I mentioned there's
so many 30 seconds ago there are so many
tough people could imagine dude this guy
like had his face basically crushed by
like a Widowmaker so like you know
what's a Widowmaker it's like uh if
you're cutting down one tree and then
you don't know that like there's some
other branches up top that are resting
on it that when you fall that they now
fall is the gist of it and that fell on
him and you know messed him up really
bad and he still like bar fights were
like a total thing with my dad's
generation and he was one of the guys
like he was [__] terrifying he had
this reconstructed face oh just ready to
punch you yeah and and you hear all
these stories like you know I went to
school with his kids about like him
beating the [__] out of this guy and
this guy and he would just give you this
like there was these guys that had a
this like thousand yard stair like I've
been to bars like inner city like that
kind of I've never been as scared as
like around like where I grew up it's
just a special hard type of people in
the generation above me my generation
was much softer sure but like my dad's
generation they would tell stories like
in the 70s college kids driving from
boisey State up to like University of
Idaho South Idaho North Idaho come to
rigin stuff they would beat him up just
for sports that's like they're
groundhogs yeah get a couple Keystone
lights and beat up these
dorks hippies and some guy with like
hair would come in and they would just
beat the [__] out of him just for
funsies holy [__] the sheriff was their
buddy or whatever so no one ever got in
trouble of course and uh yeah there was
these these guys like Dave buan and and
Randy were like the two guys where like
you just knew like don't ever upset that
person damn like they they that's some
[__] hard people man yeah that is
hard [__] core I love that um huh
what was the name of the street that you
were on Growing Up um I we moved around
quite a bit my wife thinks this is funny
we didn't really like it's so small you
don't really think of terms like street
names as far as but um there's this one
block That's crazy dude that's aw yeah
you're just going to Dan's house totally
it's like yeah we even it was so small
when you dialed somebody's number you
didn't even have to do seven digits you
just put uh it was 628 was the prefix
technically you just put the eight in it
was just eight and then the four numbers
is all you had to dial W holy [__] but
but it was how the [__] did you get out
of there I know that's crazy but North
was the block they they call this one
little Block north rigin and so I grew
up in North rins okay wow and then
Pinehurst was the part of the highway
where I live in the shed pineur sounds
nice pineur sounds pretty nice yeah K
let's talk about ladder shout out to
that ladder gang yeah we're talking
about term life insurance with no hassle
baby ladder is 100% online there's no
doctors no needles and no paperwork when
you apply for $3 million in coverage or
less it's easy to get started all you
need is take a few minutes on your phone
and your laptop just answer a few
questions about your health and you'll
find out instantly whether you're
approved yeah uh don't Jam your family
up one last time after you cro get your
Affairs in order with ladder uh what you
see is what you get there's no hidden
fees you can cancel any time you'll even
get a full refund if you change your
mind in the first 30 days cuz there good
peeps over there ladder life insurance
goes up as you AG so if you've been
thinking about Crossing that off your
to-do list now is the time every policy
is issued uh with an insurer with a long
proven history of paying claims they're
rated a and A+ by am best baby so you
know you can trust them and I like
somebody I can trust so go to ladderlife
docomo that's ladder l a d d r life.com
garbage ladderlife decom garbage gang do
it okay let's talk about that pretty
litter oh baby the prettiest litter in L
yeah you know I got a nice little kitty
cat at the house but what I don't like
is my house smelling like catpa with
pred you don't got to worry about that
spend all this time trying to get your
house clean trying to keep it fresh next
thing you know it smells like doooo in
there that's just me what up pretty
litter instantly traps odor before it
can escape into the air so your house
always smells amazing pretty litter is
lightweight low dust and one pound bag
works for up to a month without clumping
I'm all clumps baby do yourself a favor
get a little pretty litter yeah with
pretty litter uh not only are you
getting an odor-free litter experience
and way less scooping but you're also
getting a piece of mind cuz it can
uh pretty litters crystals even change
color to indicate early signs of
potential illness let you know if they
got a UTI kidney issues STDs
whatever so you can you can get the cat
uh you can get the care your cat needs
as soon as possible early indicators
that's what we're looking about around
here you know what I mean um so pretty
litter has the best litter uh you've
ever seen and you'll love it go to
prettylitter.com garbage and use code
garbage to save 20% off your first order
that's prettylitter.com garbage codar
prettylitter.com garbage code garbage
terms and conditions apply see to site
for details let's go what about the
grocery store what was that situation I
I my mom worked at the grocery store for
a while it was called Paul's Grocery and
actually uh I assume there was a Paul
yeah there was he was like the owner but
we didn't he was like a small like a
chain of little grocery stores around so
I never met the the Paul guy gotcha but
I um that was part of my delinquent
phase too the first year as I you know
shoplifted constantly from this place
place and um stealing yeah you Ste steal
uh I feel like I'm again a thousand
years old uh cassettes sure okay or like
CDs then like that or like uh there was
like Playboy behind the counter so you'd
throw you get behind the counter well I
worked there like bad and when I clean
up you know it's like whoops uh Playboy
goes in the garbage and you take it out
back by the dumpster and then you just
take it out later man a Playboy in that
town must have been like the you might
as well been PornHub dude you were the
plug I would have been Pages uh I I I I
told a story at the end of my not this
trying to get better but the previous
special about when I worked at that
grocery store like the most sexually
ridiculous thing I've ever done I'm
listening it was when I worked there I
worked in the did a little bit of
everything it a small store but
sometimes I'd help this lady Ronda work
to produce and Ronda was voluptuous and
she sounds it every Rhonda is and I was
a horny teenager and I remember like I
you know virgin I was a a very awkward
uh didn't my virginity until like right
after summer after senior year or the
end but so high school we're talking
yeah High School yeah so it's very
awkward around girls and um very horny
and I was working with Ronda I'm like
and I got this crazy thought I was
looking at the bananas and I'm like you
know banan's kind of like like a the
dick of the fruit worlds and I'm like so
if you just took the banana part out the
peel would be like a vagina that's that
got in my head okay and I took a banana
into the workplace bathroom and [__]
the peel Jesus and then threw it in the
trash and then went back to work and
they was nervous the whole rest of the
day oh yeah that someone was going to
somehow put the crime together there's
DNA he left you left yourself vulnerable
he went in horny he came out not horny a
banana banana peel in a small town like
that I would imagine one banana would
come up missing yeah there's a count
there was only eight of them yeah
exactly that was in my head like they
had knew exactly how many bananas holy
[__] and how did you okay how did you
get out of there uh what was the move
out of there I was so focused the last
two years on College not even I didn't
even know what I wanted to study but
it's like that was the only way I was
getting out okay was like get to college
so I um I applied to a couple schools
Gonzaga gave me some scholarships gag
what you went to Gonzaga yeah holy [__]
went from there to Gonzaga with a
scholarship yeah like academic stuff not
Sports kid yeah yeah so I got to I got
to go to Gonzaga and uh and then that
was like a game changer that like yeah
that'll open up your eyes a credited
institution hell of a basketball team
hell oh my basketball team it changed
when I was there I graduated in 99 and
that was the year they had that crazy
Elite 8 run out of nowhere previous to
that like nothing at all we would get
ham like two years before they became
the big Cinderella Story we would get
hammered uh in our dorms you know bring
like a um a thing of like vodka
cranberry whatever like some kind of
like I can't think of the um oh my God
not Tumblr but just whatever you can one
of these but like not it has a ther than
you like a thing you man you are from a
small
town I put it in my J what is with fancy
people he's got one of those uh
moonshine uh no we would
just we would was there moonshine in
your hometown did people make their own
booze no not that I'm not that I'm aware
of okay it was more like uh they called
it crank what crank but like meth I
think yeah that's
meth any moonshine n a lot of [__]
lot of
Crank what in the Hell's Angels who's
doing prank that's crazy but we would go
down and just sit to you know uh was
empty empty yeah we sit by the floor
drunk Heckle our own team like no one
gave a [__] about them and all of a
sudden it became his Powerhouse yeah
they blew up man yeah holy cow okay any
injuries as a kid uh weird
injuries um I this this is going to make
me sound like more and more of a bumpkin
but I did have a a facial
don't worry about that it's already it's
already done also like I don't think you
like how you Vis visually appear now
yeah and the person I know you as now I
don't see how it's the same guy you know
what I mean like but you do have like a
a rough ex steel you could be from a
small logging down but he looks very
polished as well at the same
time well put together very well put
together I imagine you're pretty good
with the with the hands though seem like
a pretty tough gu I I can like uh oh
well I mean was there a lot of of fights
growing up like little scraps like
around school like that but never like I
was always um I didn't I didn't have
that like Killer Instinct like I
remember like this neighbor kid like
example of me fighting like there this
neighbor kid was messing with my sister
so I did jump the fence and I did throw
him on the ground and I punched him a
few times but like in the stomach and I
thought about punched him in the face
and I'm like this feels excessive yeah I
feel like a lot of times the comic the
comic personality doesn't have that you
know that Killer Instinct right like
like I feel like if I could it just
didn't I didn't feel morally okay with
it um did you guys go to church when you
were a kid was it religious uh there was
a lot of religion like fundamentalism in
town like my neighbor act actually that
kid was the preacher son I just talked
about like uh got to be somebody I got
kicked out the kid you're roughed up
over the face yeah I got kicked out of
youth group there was a a couple things
like fundamental stuff but I was um I
would dabble in it honestly just for
something to do but I was um a very
curious kid and I remember like uh going
to this youth group and when they would
bring up stuff like okay if you don't
get saved by Jesus then you don't go to
heaven and I was a kid be like what
about people who never met Jesus like in
Asia and I remember the lady being like
it's just I listen I'm just reading out
of the book buddy come on quit jamming
me up coming kids is poking holes in the
story over here man they made a new rule
for me they're like no more questions
you don't get to ask these question and
then also if you get kicked out three
times you're banned forever and I got
kicked out the next three times for
asking questions and then didn't didn't
get to go back to youth group aome real
Ravel Rouser and then and then this is
that lady her June cook was the youth
group leader her husband was a teacher
at our school that later became like the
superintendent for the school district
who got in trouble for polygamy because
God told him he needed more wives like
that's the kind of area like real
Backwoods weird [__] damn
huh this is something where where is a
lot oh the injury sorry the injury I got
uh Taekwondo I I had to drive an hour to
take these [__] lessons from this mad
man Larry Duke was like something of a
what kind of a stat was it in his house
names are awesome a strip mall where was
it uh no it was kind of Larry Duke like
it it was in Mall Idaho and it was just
um you would call smoking where you at
[__] get in here let me kick your head
you would call it a strip mall but
really beating up kids in the garage oh
it was it was ridiculous looking back um
it was just like little offices little
office space in the I don't know five or
six units okay in this two-story
building and that was one of them maybe
there was like a realtor and something
else Den or something yeah exactly and
uh and he it was real Loosey Goosey like
he would just throw you in like you've
been in a month I've been in a month and
he would just throw me in against to
spar basically be a punching bag against
people who've been training for years
and this this one little guy was really
good and he would kick the [__] out of
me and uh and he kicked me in the balls
a couple times in this thing and I was
like one though I know it was it was
very F dirty it was not regulated at all
uh and now salt in your eyes and now I'm
trying to guard my ballmore and he did
like some spinning hook kick and caught
me in the in the cheek and knocked me
unconscious and then just probably
concussion yeah and then just like
shattered this cheekbone and then the
guy was basically like well you should
have blocked and didn't offer to do I
had to drive myself keep your hands up
keep your hands up keep your hands up
and this Vibe of kind of like you're
such a [__] like when I whed about it
my mom made me wait three days to go to
the hospital I was like on the floor I'm
like I think I'm really [__] up and
she's like Dad just take some adill
because we didn't have health insurance
sure so so finally I went and the doctor
was basically like why did you wait like
yeah you have multiple breaks [__] up
your face is messed up but that was that
was an injury and then I think I crushed
one of my balls on a monkey bar accident
Jesus cuz I fell from the top of the
monkey bar this like fourth fifth grade
landed on the Bottom Rung one leg on
each side neither feet touching the
ground like all my weight on my balls
sure and I just remember it's like the
worst pain laying there and then uh my I
have one ball that's still pretty [__]
up really really yeah like I've went to
the doctor before it's fine it's just
not the same shape it was it's a little
got a little mashed they think yeah bad
case of monkey
blls like putting a penny on the train
tracks that's good luck
though lucky ball now regular checkups
yearly check you would drive the hour
and do that stuff right if I did yearly
checkups I don't know if I I yeah but
you would you would drive like the hour
broken face you didn't take him to the
hospital not getting the physical it's
kind of a miracle you're alive right now
I'm saying that's what my sister and I
teas her mom we like how the [__] are we
alive like how did we make it is your
mom are they is anyone still there yeah
yeah my mom is still there Mom and
stepdad are still there and uh uh
Grandma my grandpa passed uh basically
like my grandma and grandpa were more
like parents to me got they were kind of
like the glue and stuff
and my grandma's still there The
Matriarch now swimming in the river
hiking all that stuff dangerous outdoor
activities I would assume like riding
your bike you're saying Canyons I assume
you were constantly surrounded by danger
uh rattlesnakes you know like there I
never we don't like Rattlers on this
program but um that was always something
you like just looked out for I guess
Bears no bears no bears no Bears I mean
there's black bears around but they're
not going to uh come at you bears where
we come from that's Bears dude there's
uh yeah I mean technically there are
mountain lines I never saw any of them
growing up when You' walk around in the
woods usually you'd have a gun um even
as a kid you'd like little 22 or
something what age you start carrying a
gun wood this is like a yes this is a
very unrepresented part of the show we
never had anybody from a 400 person town
this rural four-year-old walking around
the woods with some nickel on him I know
a br broken face yeah probably like 11
with a rifle mhm rifle yeah man that's
pretty cool I had a Super
Soaker sixth grade but the the river was
too uh it's like salmon Riv the big
Salmon River too rough too rough and so
you I was always just my mom made me
paranoid about drowning and stuff so he
didn't really swim too much there were
some beaches but you couldn't go out
very far like was there a pool in your
town like did you swim as a kid no some
lady owned a pool so some like it was
like I remember there's like one lady in
town that supposedly had a pool I never
saw it no one saw
I never went to her house can you swim I
can swim not very well not very well um
Summers I'd go uh stay with my dad like
as I got a little older okay and this
one summer this lady he was dating was
working at like a nursing home or
something and so I'd kind of hang out
there during the day at the nursing home
yeah like he he's working construction
Lear dude learning to swim at a nursing
home some old lady taught me how to swim
there that's crazy I don't remember her
name man holy
[__] was there any quads or dirt bikes
ATV type stuff growing up in the town or
not really yeah like there wasn't many
trails that were good they they were
around but it's a it's a weird geography
it's very steep gotcha and so yes like
my mom like later like got into like
four-wheelers and stuff so so my stepdad
would have four-wheelers where he your
mom later got into four-wheelers yeah
with my stepdad they got some that's an
aru garbage first right there your mom
got into four-wheeler she loves the
four-wheeler she did she did for a while
she loved the four-wheeler yeah what was
your bicycle situation what was your
bike H my bike I can't I had a a huffy
okay for a while standard issue and then
I had some kind of Kmart uh uh mountain
bike but you know like a like what some
cheapy model mountain bike okay that I
just ride uh you know around back and
forth in town you guys drove out to the
Kmart you got that that was like a
special trip oh yeah that I'm sure that
was like a a huge like Christmas know
present yeah I was going to ask you
about Christmas how was that it was I
will say you know like you know we
didn't have like a lot of money growing
but my mom made a really good effort and
my grandparents to like get us lots so
we actually got probably spoiled when it
came to toys tons of toys but it was um
Christmas Eve you'd open up your
presents except for like uh one big
present sure the way my mom did but
you'd go to like we go to my
grandparents house then we go to my
great-grandparents house like open
presents at each place okay and then
come back s was nice it was nice
actually yeah the Christmas Eve present
opening but that is a that is a c we've
heard that before where they they do it
Christmas Eve and then save one big one
right you did the reverse maybe you
would open one we would open one on
Christmas Eve I think that's more
traditional right you do like one on
Christmas Eve and the rest on Christmas
yeah it was always pajamas my mom would
lay a fresh pair of pajamas on our bed
before we went to MK that was your that
was your oh are you we raised Catholic
yeah okay yeah my my uh my wife Lindsay
was raised Catholic and there's so many
Traditions like what is it St Nicholas
Day and with like she has all these
crazy sounds like a guy who just walked
out of the
woods Nicholas you're talking about New
Year's Eve that's like something like
now now Patrick's Day no it's like St
Easter no it's like it's its own thing
it's like I thought it was like St
Nicholas around Christmas she's polish
Catholic I don't know I feel like
Lindsay is like now like what is going
on but it's like has to do with like all
I know is that the kids get a [__]
shoe stuck with toys on this special
same day that's that's that's something
the kids in Vegas told you no that's
isn't that clouse or something that that
might be an Eastern European thing yeah
maybe it's from her polish family I feel
like my my wife's German I feel they do
something with the night before so like
that Christmas devil does there's
something involved
Theus I didn't like that at all there's
something with the shoes and they put
pennies in the shoes or something I got
nothing on shoes but I got a St Nicholas
Day uh observed on the fifth or 6th of
December in Western Christian countries
uh it has to do with the it's the feast
day of St Nicholas yeah her family
celebrates celebrates that I maybe it's
a family tradition what the [__] I've
been getting ripped off this whole time
missing pre [__] pregame to Christmas
the [__] exactly oh man okay um this
one's putting me through the ringer got
to say I did not I didn't know this
going into it and I've not I haven't
talked about much of this uh in standup
either it's like more observational
really yeah for the longest time maybe
as I've gotten older I feel better now
but I didn't want to like I it's
fascinating crazy well I go back home a
lot and I think I was always nervous
like I didn't want to the people feel
like I P how you get there you have to
drive what airport do you fly into
there's no airport close there's uh the
closest fly into lardan basically fly
you would fly into Boise and then drive
three hours North all right that's not
that bad yeah I assume pretty snowy in
the winter probably treacherous
conditions it's a weird little banana
belt like microclimate where if you go
an hour in either direction from where I
grew up yes but where I grew up weirdly
warm like one of the warmest parts of
Idaho and so not much snow this place
should be on the Moon dude you it's it's
crazy if you look picture if you get a a
rigin's Idaho you'll be like what the
[__] how is this uh how play that it's
beautiful I'm sure it's got to be oh my
God yes okay so that's that's the town
just in the bottom of the bending along
the river that's rigin what the [__]
dude that is a I'll send you these
pictures that is a the tiny historic
town wow that's it that river is be yeah
that's you really are in a valley there
that's not there's not a whole lot of uh
you ever walk up those mountains
actually uh yeah there's it is I do
sound more more like a weirdo but it's
like there wasn't there is a little park
downtown but it's not very big but like
but because it's so steep it's hard to
find areas with a lot of like flat like
to throw a football around a big flat
area lot of there's not a lot of open
flat space no and so there was a
semetery above North rigin and that's
where I would play as a kid you play in
the cemetery yeah you go the
and like my grandma thought it was like
weird that I wanted there heades a
touchdown and there was like a big area
that didn't have headstones it was like
no headstones yet so you just kind of
like I don't know that's even worse
that's like a Potter's ground yeah it's
crazy where they put all the homeless
bunch of unmarked Graves and the
mountain behind that is where you could
you could hike it up there's no Trail
really just like deer Trails but you
could make it up in like two three hours
well there was this mountain across the
river from where I grew up there's like
the town is on one side of the river and
on the other side there's just uh just
mountains and it always looked about the
same size of my brain as the one above
the cemetery so I made a deal with my
son I'm like when you get 12 I I'll take
you up to the top of that mountain I
thought it was going to be like a
three-hour hike we brought one bottle of
water each and like donuts and like and
we were like going to was going be a
nice little day out oh it it took us
like 10 hours and I thought I thought I
was going to [__] die dehydration was
kicking in like I was trying not to show
how scared I was in front of my son my
legs were cramping up and then my
daughter insisted on doing the same hike
a couple years later and I decided to uh
double up and bring two bottles of water
there you go not even close to enough
it's just another death hike so I've
done I've done one of those mountains
twice and never again so you take them
back there somewhat often yeah cuz my
grand let know what it was like actually
okay sorry oh no there's just one
property where my grandma lives that's
been in our family for six Generations
now or something ho like Yellowstone
[__] yeah so it's like it's just cool to
go a cool yeah where are you at now
cordelane Idaho so you're still in Idaho
yeah I moved to La for a while and then
with my kids my ex is in Spokane which
is right across the border gotcha and it
just didn't make I was flying him down
like every month and it was too much and
so yeah actually Before Time suck took
off um that was like a Hail Mary this
podcast that change I thought my career
was over I know what you're talking
about oh yeah we're all about hail Mar
here baby you're sitting in a buzzer
beater right now pal I I mean I was
ready I was ready to follow her into
real estate like she walked away from
her production job she worked in film
and TV when we met in La like costume
Department okay and when we went to
cordelan uh I was able to you know we
able to buy a place with at that time
like Pandora was spending me a fair
amount get like royalties that was what
gave us like the down payment money okay
but I thought like well I'm getting a
little older I'm going to be in
cordelane there's no other Comics around
this is probably it and then did time
suck and like thank god it worked
because that was the last chance but
yeah so cord so we're going to be there
for a few more years till the kids are
out of high school and then who knows
[__] love it [__] man that's
[__] incredible I just want to go
back a little bit to reagin just for a
minute then we'll start talking about
now um I'm scared to ask this what were
the vacations like were there
vacations did you go anywhere no vac we
had one vacation uh that my family went
on growing up my mom saved up for years
for went to poet one
time that's the C I'm looking at a m
yeah
hilarious those fancy pants is over in
poock with their cable
TV I was I've heard you make 9,000 jokes
I was like what the [__] is B
dude we uh we camp a little bit like in
it's like but like nearby but it's
basically you're already kind of camping
yeah you're on a concrete floor yeah and
uh my mom I mean it is kind of adorable
looking back but she uh she had this
giant J basically like big old jug thing
like some antique thing she found that
was huge that she would fill with uh
quarters and stuff that's awesome did
that for years and then took uh my
sister and I along with my aunt and uh
to The Coin Star it was a big vacation
Coin Star we went to the coin star no we
went to uh Disneyland you did oh there
you go so that that was our big like uh
vacation was Disneyland that's great
yeah that's awesome huh that must have
been an eyeopener yeah like I I I wish I
could like almost go back and like what
was I thinking because I mean I remember
driving through LA and I'd never been in
a city like that before um your first
time out of a rural setting was
Vegas this was before so before Vegas
junior high was when my went a vacation
with Mom and then Vegas was the first
time I'd lived in a place like that yeah
so Disney was the first real Disney was
the first I mean we lived in Anchorage
in Alaska which is it's not it's not
that big I've never been but I could
yeah when the first time you got cable
was it at your dad's house in Vegas um
well yeah I guess it would have been
what was that like but we did well I we
did though what was that like like the
first time seeing Nickelodeon or maybe a
you know the a Cinemax movie or
something it was right before that
actually where I got to see everything
and I don't to this day I don't
understand I'll have to ask my stepdad I
don't understand how they got these
things but there we didn't have cable
but when I was like seventh eighth grade
somewhere in there maybe seventh grade
they got this satellite satellite TV but
not like dish satellite it was like this
black
market I don't understand how it works
but I've talked about it in shows and
other people have like oh yeah I
remember that too and you would get
these [__] massive like NASA sat like
big concrete foundation it would slowly
rotate to point towards things I
remember a couple of people would have
backyard and stuff yeah yeah huge dish
with the [__] roof would collapse if
you put it up there oh yeah massive and
there was this thing called the blackbox
disc Scrambler and I don't know who
[__] sold these but you wouldn't pay
a subscription you would just get this
disc Scrambler sure and it opened up
every single Channel yeah it did and oh
yeah and that's uh that's how my mom
actually C jerking off uh is
uh I where all the goddamn banana peels
go you must have been in there wailing
on yourself oh holy [__] it was a spice
Channel and like at that time in
Penthouse but we had like the Scrambler
was in the living room on top of the TV
and I had I guess you'd call like a
mirror TV because because we didn't have
cable or something traditional you
couldn't just get new auxiliary cables
and have your own but we could somehow
mirror that TV to the one in my rooms so
I would have to watch whatever's on the
living room W TV and if my mom and
stepdad went to bed I could turn it to
HBO whatever and watch a show or I could
turn it to spice channel would you have
to leave that TV on an the living room
on yep volume no not volume it could be
off actually you just had to have the
Scrambler turned to that channel Goa but
it but it showed a display anyone
walking by would know what channel was
on yeah and so you had to this gamble
where you'd have to go to the living
room after my mom and step down to sleep
turn it to the spice Channel come back
and I'd have to do prenal unlock I
figured out how to do the prenal unlock
code so I hacked it basically and I have
to like unut a code back in to make sure
they didn't know I hacked it is this
whole thing it's like deleting your
cookies you go to your you go to your
room you jerk off and then you go back
and then turn it back to like I don't
know the Hallmark Channel or something
sure my mom came out one night and just
saw that it was on the wrong channel
it's on the right channel the right
Channel and I do think this is a little
weird cuz so now she must know I'm
jerking off or probably cuz and she just
no knock she opened my door and just
goes I don't think we should be doing
that should we and to shut the door damn
that's a pretty good play though I'll
give you that she didn't blow up your
spot entirely get the hell out of
here [__] man talk about earning it holy
[__] I'm such a dirt bag I'm already
coming up with ways I would I would been
like you got to put the remote in front
of the box I was already I was already
thinking about a tissue box or something
just a piece of electrical tape come on
Dan put something in front of the TV but
when we got that dis Scrambler it was
probably like it was a it became my
house became the cool house immediately
sure and I I do remember my classmates
coming jot jerk spot you got tits on TV
if it was boys been living in the future
in RI but I remember introducing kids to
MTV and just having them be like whoa
that's crazy that's [__] awesome
[__] music what like you knew these
things existed but you just didn't have
access saw them yeah God damn that's
[__] awesome was there what was the
Taxidermy situation around the house was
there any oh my stepdad
so no my dad like no heads hanging on
the wall or anything like that no that
would be around at places for sure okay
actually my wife said no cuz I've I've
uh just had some antlers show up in the
garage the other day she hates that
stuff what do you mean show up I went
went hunting and then like had the place
like you know yeah do do it up whatever
but I don't even I'll probably put that
in the shed I'm not even really big into
the mounts either but okay it meant it
meant a lot to my dad it was like a
hunting trip with him so yeah sure what
was was what was the heat situation in
the house what what were you heating the
house with when you were a kid oh uh of
course wood wood stove wood fireplace
enclosed or just an open like a
fireplace closed you get these ones yeah
they would close up and have a little
chimney stack that went out through the
trailer roof or whatever couple of my
cousins had that they always make fun of
me we had a coal stove when I was when I
was young oh a coal stove load the coal
in I never see like West Coast and
especially I never coal was just not a
thing yeah what does a coal stove even
look like it just looks like um yeah it
looks like a kind like a fireplace yeah
like a wood burning stove and you just
you you throw the coal in the top like
if a p like a pellet stove now yeah yeah
that's what it was like thing would cook
really and it just Cooks it down to
nothing yeah and you you just shovel the
ash out shovel all that [__] out yeah oh
okay [__] it would [__] your sinuses
a bad I see that like that I my only
associate with now I picture you like
living on like a steamboat or something
that's every time he talks I've seen
I've seen the house and I still picture
with like coal on his face and stuff his
hands are black Got The Black Lung huh
okay all right man that is a [__]
origin
story do you wear underwear under your
bathing
suit now let's talk about now yeah let's
talk about now so what's the house like
you're in now single family home you
said shed split level Rancher split
level Rancher okay yeah my wife does a
great job of like uh making it has like
a mid-century modern kind of look inside
architecturally not really like that but
she she brings she brings all the the
class and sophistication any any that we
have comes from her bigger town like
more C Lane yeah like 150,000 in the
little area next Spokane where there's a
you know Comedy Club there and more
people gotcha all right all right what
kind of car you whipping around in uh
Ford F150 love it oo look at you nice
what year uh 2016 nice got a gun rack on
that no but I I don't have a gun rack on
it but I I do have guns but but uh it is
weird again looking back growing up kids
would hunt after school and so yeah
there was tons of guns in the in the
high schol parking lot gun racks yeah
crazy that's awesome you carry any
nickel on you now no some might know ask
him the same thing man dude the second
he walked in I'm like this guy might
have a gun no I I don't care either
round I but like um I don't carry it
around is it a
no it's always in arms length
though it ain't on me but it's on me no
no I don't I don't have uh do you keep
anything near the bed yes you do yeah a
a piece or like a 9mm all
right man you're a real man dud I it's
like a kitchen knife or something like
that I got a little baseball bat next to
my bed I got a Trent and thunderbat from
the [__] Triple A leag I haven't
known I haven't known Mr cuings long but
I know he don't miss now I bet he
doesn't God
damn okay all right huh Dan cumins holy
[__] [__] man's man I know I'm
slipping off my seat over here hit me
with the caliber real quick hang on okay
okay
um slightly attracted to
you slightly this guy
rules it's so funny to like different
areas had it because like um I remember
when I went to LA lived there for a
while I felt like I was a gigantic dude
but like you guys want to go beat up
some college
kids down at UCLA trying to come on
let's go [__] punch some college KS
uh but like where I grew up I'm like
average size shoot shoot squirrels in
the park s you can't do that here or
where I grew up like I'm not as into
guns so it's just so funny yeah you're a
milder version of where you come
from are you uh do you drink are you are
you Boozer what's the goto uh go-to
drink of choice at the moment uh oh man
we we're at some Pisco there's a Pisco
bar in our hotel here in New York and I
love a Pisco Sour Rand it's a Peruvian
drink it's like their liquor like
country's National liquor basically huh
very refined that's it's a very refined
answer I'm I'm only having that here at
home it's it's generally like a a
whiskey Ginger or uh gin and tonic and
we just like you know vary the Gin vary
the whiskey what kind of whisky you you
knocking around like for a easy one like
Bullet bourbon okay or like the standard
like Makers Mark um I'm a makers man
myself you have a bar set up at the
house you do lulan is like a scotch I
really like yeah and then jyn um I like
Empress Jen a lot right now monkey 47's
another good one ah yes goddamn
gentleman over here monkey 47's German I
believe it how often do you have a
cocktail at the house um about three or
four nights a week but like one or two
sure and then that's a gentleman way man
dude you bump out that I mean you got
imported gin so the the kids are in high
school and they live with you y uh son's
now in college okay and they split time
uh between our house and their mom's
house like 30 minutes away okay so now
it's just uh my daughter Monroe is she's
a sophomore okay so yeah a couple more
years so you guys do dinner at night and
stuff like that like traditional family
sit down at the table Monroe is super
busy in sports and stuff like that so
basically it's around her schedule when
she doesn't have yeah a bunch of sports
obligations then yeah we'll do dinner at
the table together who's cooking you or
the misses I it's probably a sore
subject cuz I never cook I uh it's
Lindsay yes my my wife yeah I uh she's
still I I don't know that I've she would
probably say that I have not made a meal
for her I maybe made spaghetti or
something okay but like I thought I was
going to be like this great in
it you haven't touched your rattlesnake
come on get that snake chili uh this is
something that we were just talking
about at the live show in Denver any uh
ever pick up any roadkill as the family
no back in the day no we
didn't okay maybe like not even really
poach I mean no not you get like we do
it like you know get tags or whatever
okay where where did you meet your wife
and where is she from just for a little
bit of background yeah I met Lindsay at
uh oh my God it was this show called it
was Nickelodeon was trying to do briefly
standup comedy and they had that Mom's
Night Out Show yes okay so they had
remember and then they like they ran out
of moms and then it was basically they
called Dan
com it got opened up first to like women
who obviously have Mom all women have
moms so it's like okay women can talk
about their moms and then it was just
like anybody with the mom so anybody I
vividly remember this yeah yeah and I
did a taping in La for that and uh had
done a few things like that before and I
guess Jade did be the word but I I knew
this was not going to be a career break
like moment so I I was like I didn't
really care about it and Lindsay was the
Wardrobe uh oh my God I can never
remember the terms she she was the
person coordinator coordinator yeah like
you know like make sure you're wearing
stuff right for camera all that stuff
and uh her telling of this is she hated
me because I wouldn't get back to her
like uh in my experience in the past
with ask for your sizes and all that
stuff and they want to make me make you
wear stuff that you don't normally wear
and so I was like you know what I'm just
going to ignore them and I'm just going
to show up with what I want to wear and
that's just going to be it and so I did
talk to her like the day before and she
was you know kind of annoyed and then I
showed up and just thought she was I was
single at that time and just like uh I
don't know slutt it up basically and and
thought thought she was super cute and
was trying to like peacock around the G
just being a douche like no shirts you
know like hey is this over here like
trying to be weird and man this guy's
awesome his mood just take your what's
up
ladies and then there was this they
wanted these they wanted these intertial
shot for stuff in between the standup
segments and there Angela Hoover Angela
was a comic
and they were like somehow we got to
talking and there's that Dirty Dancing
move where you pick the girl like do
that uhhuh so I wanted to do that with
and basically to show off to Lindsay
like look what I can do like a gorilla
guy and uh I think I broke my finger
doing that she she she Twisted when I
was up there and something popped and it
was messed up he starts crying you drive
her to the hospital huge yeah huge uh
yeah failure well so that happens and
then I also when I left after the set I
grabbed Kira sanovich was there too and
I and I grabbed her pants by mistake
just I don't know in a hurry to leave
grab my pants and then now Lindsay is
the water has to track down who has
car's pants and I Ed that as an excuse
to text her back or email her back
that's a real castanza move I respect
that even I just watched that yeah and I
was like uh I guess I don't even
remember that I said exactly this but I
said something like do you want to come
she says I do would you want to come
watch some uh TV on the couch basically
Netflix and chill before that term was
there got she sent an email back saying
like if you want to ask me out be a man
get some [__] balls pick up the phone
and actually call me she's like this is
not how I do that or whatever and I was
like o I like her and so I did call her
and we talked and it was a great
conversation and then when she came over
for that first date she brought all this
like stuff from Walgreen like a splint
and all these things that I would I was
I'm better finally but I was just we
don't have health insurance we can't
afford this I literally would just oh my
God I have you're a doctor there's too
many there probably not time but I I
have the most [__] up stories about
about trying to do home surgery uh to
avoid going to the doctor never worked
always backfired horribly of course like
had multiple doctors when I would have
to come in later because it got worse
and I would tell them the story I've had
two uh two I guess two doctors not
joking be like you're an idiot like just
like look at me and be like like why
would you do that don't ever do that
again so I just thought it was so cool
that Lindsay like thought of that it
meant so much I was like oo I like and
then it just yeah just went from there
damn man that's [__] sweet yeah she
sounds like a real one man she is she's
awesome that's all right and where's she
from Cleveland Cleveland okay yeah her
family's like all bunch of uh longtime
Cleveland people Polish people in
Cleveland okay what uh what do do you
guys go away now what are the vacations
like now do the kids know what you went
through as a kid you know it's funny
kids are so into their own stuff they do
they've been there but I don't think
they'll have perspective till they until
they get older of course you know it's
just like with what I do too like they
couldn't care care less you know you're
a dork to them essentially until they
spend the summer at the Swifts
House show them what it's like but uh
yeah we've taken some pretty cool we did
the Machu Picchu in Peru nice was
amazing and then Greece was a big
one just got back gu's classy Machu picu
no Greece Greece Greece oh my God I
could have I could have stayed in Greece
where'd you go in Greece uh we stayed in
Athens one night and then Santorini for
like four days we didn't do sanini we we
went by it on the ferry or whatever but
we did
mikos it was fine but with the kids I'm
like no this is probably not the right
Vibe wish we would have done sanini
instead and then we did cre and Athens
there you go and I was like I love this
country I could stay here yeah it's all
right man yeah World traveler this guy I
know just just recently yeah when did
you get your
passport well you know actually now that
I say that I did get my passport I did a
semester abroad I got to go to a study
in London for a semester in college
there you go what was your major at at
Gaga isn't it isn't
Ito contract obligated to yell that
anytime England comes up what was your
major uh psychology okay so you have a
psychology degree yeah a great [__]
school too yeah it was a good educated
man right here yeah let the concrete
floors fool you gang [__] smart huh
when was the first time you had
Nutella oh man I don't think I had
Nutella until I think I don't think I
found if I didn't find out maybe I found
out about it in London but I I can't
remember cuz I don't remember eating
when I came back
but I know Lindsay either introduced it
or reintroduced it because she traveled
a bunch she went on tour with Rihanna as
a like part of their sty like wardrobe
uh to dress the dancers and stuff and so
she went to all kinds of crazy countries
and brought that back and man that stuff
is so good you tell sound like like
ancient spices she went to all different
kinds of countries and brought back
Nutella gold incense and Nutella she's
been all over the far away
lands
that's that's amazing though I dude I I
don't think I had it until my late 20s
early 30s it's everybody's girl
introduces it to them every every guy
you talk to is like my girlfriend had it
my wife had it yeah like crepe banana
slices and Nutella I'm like this is the
best yeah you make the bed every morning
nope no no what is the bed situation at
the house king size king size I think I
think I think my wife she'll make it
later though I never I'm okay with it
being messy but she doesn't like it to
be messy how are you sleeping you sleep
on your side on your back side side how
many pillows
m one or two usually just one one just
behind your head that's it yeah two is
angles my neck too much any seiling fan
or fan on you when you sleep uh I like a
little humidifier and a yeah fan and and
I and I have this app that makes like a
Conant White Noise no TV when you go to
bed mm just a lot of white noise TV in
the bedroom no TV in the bedroom no TV
in the but I take an edible most nights
to help go to sleep too all right okay
huh uh let me ask you this let's say you
get um a deli sandwich yeah all right
you unwrap the paper yeah and you got
chips would you put the chips on the
paper or leave them in the bag uh in the
paper so I can access them faster all
right interesting will you put chips on
a sandwich if you're at home you make a
sandwich this feels like sorry this I
know I love this it feels like this
psych test that I'm failing like at the
end like yeah he's a sociopath he a
[__] I knew it I I got that Vibe I
saw his eyes you put him on the paper
yeah he peas one by one sorry what was
the question um I forget um will you put
chips on the sandwich oh uh I have done
that yeah sometimes it's good but not
always okay H how's a credit score
pretty good actually nice uh yeah what
kind of plastic you throwing around you
got an MX Visa Master Card MX do the
Delta MX to get all the sky we're a
Delta MX family ourselves where you
where you clothes shopping you're you're
a well put together guy got a good sense
of fashion that's that's that makes she
was a sty she's a stylist um I mean I
definitely like gravitate like you know
she doesn't just dress me but she helps
like what do you think of this what do
you think of this um good to have I
think I got this stuff in Missoula
Montana actually just like random like
just saw the shirt I think it's a rooka
it is yeah I like the way they fit you
like truffle fries no okay I don't like
truff I don't care about truffles I I
always feel like I supposed to care
about truffles stinks yeah just like a
weird flavor to me I fan you peeing in
the shower yeah brush your teeth in
there look I whisper with my wife there
uh uh no I don't brush my teeth in there
but I shave in there I shave in the
shower and uh I'll PE in the shower do
you have a mirror in there mhm like a
little tiny mirror and you do you shave
with a like a like shave shave all the
way down yeah just yeah just with a
little razor yep oh just not the you
keep the beard all the time oh yeah yeah
yeah it just kind of like grows out
until I get back to the so you're just
cleaning it up in there you're not fully
shaving in the shower no uhuh that'd be
crazy H let's say you get a sixpack of
beers or at the house do you take the
cans out out of the container or like
out of the ring or the 12 or you just
put the whole box or the whole thing in
there I put the whole box in there it's
trashy put the whole box in there but I
respect it you guys have a garage fridge
yeah what's in there uh ice cream uh
Deer uh like hearts uh a lot of like um
just random things that the kids like
basically sodas juices stuff like that
the freezer no just like um uh I don't
know random like uh things
like individual meals and stuff I guess
you know uh wantons like like Trader
Joe's like stuff I can't gotta got you
shopping at Trader Joe's yeah Lindsay
stops to Trader Joe's not bad can you
park a car in the garage or is it filled
with [__] uh I don't par we could
probably get to I I just park out in the
driveway um Lindsay parks in the garage
though one car in a garage is all right
who's cutting the grass ah this is
embarrass I I did cut okay I I felt
embarrassed about this I did cut the
grass myself I like cutting the grass
but I got so busy this how I justifi but
so busy with podcast stuff everything
that Lindsay talked me into like have a
lawn service got I will say the older
men in my neighborhood uh heavily
frowned on that sure whatever manpo I
built up substantial drop that's like
that that's that even with the F-150 and
the nickel I tell him to [__] beat it
[__] out of here what you do when you go
home take that shirt off wash the truck
in the
garage just come out like a man you shut
the [__] up pop a couple into the air uh
what mow are we using do you have a p
how big how big is the backyard uh it's
like the lot size is standard for the
like a third of an acre size okay but a
pretty decent backyard but I like the uh
I mowe Lawns as a kid just for like
extra money or whatever and I love the
self-propelled so it's not a riding lawn
mower but oh yeah just a self-propelled
did you have a self-propelled when you
were a kid not at first I had like some
did you ever use one of those I know
which kind you're talking about um there
was one lady's lawn I didn't mow for
very long that insisted on that kind of
mower like like no engine just the you
know what we're talking about Toby oh
yeah those are those are Homer Simpson
one yeah yeah it's like a wheel covered
in a paper cutter you only see it on
like The Three Stooges yeah somebody was
always getting their hand caught so I've
used one but h no thanks all right I
mean I'm I got to think all the info I
need to render a decision while vexing
yeah I mean yeah I mean I I'm just
having fun at this
point to be honest with you you ever
drink out of a measuring
cup uh yeah I'm sure I've done that okay
you guys have a toaster oven at the
house now no no toaster I've had I've
had a toaster oven in the past but I
don't I don't know that I've ever
actually used a toast Roven okay I know
I've been in homes with toast rovins
George Foreman Grill oh my God I how you
GNA make Thanksgiving dinner I feel like
I did have I did have a George Foreman
grill a long time ago I I didn't use I
think I got tired of cleaning it or
something okay yeah but I had one of
those grills the infomercial George
Foreman Grill but not anymore you're a
coffee drinker yeah wow constant coffee
are you buying coffee or you making
coffee both we French Press at home
sometimes it's more like grind French
Press French Press you grind the be you
grind yourself yeah really see he's very
refined in certain really coffee and
booze that's where he's refined but then
I get a lot of mochas too I'll go to
like the little drive-thru whatever
coffee shop and get a mocha who's
cutting the hair just whoever's at this
uh this place Mavericks I go to in
cordelane and it used to be the the
owner there but then he moved on and I
just whoever happens to be there you do
massages Manny petties anything like
that no uh I I have I have done massages
I would like to do regular massages but
I haven't done them very often but they
are nice and then uh I don't think I've
ever done a manicure no I don't think so
my my wife I did um just because it's
gross I had what I thought was toe a
toenail fungus for a long time and my
toe was so [__] up like like the the
the toenail was like kind of coming off
of my big toe and it was all mangled
it's always the big toe and I would try
to uh it turns out like I I just had to
in the end I had to have this thing
where they just slic part of your
toenail off on the sides yeah to make it
like lay flat that's all it wasn't even
a fungus but for the longest time I just
didn't feel comfortable like every time
I tried to like cut this gross toenail
down I would just cut too far and make
it worse and Limp around so I started
going to have somebody else cut my and I
was embarrassing like can you cut my
[__] nasty Monster Toe um so I did do
pedicures for that but like but trash
he's getting medical pedicures over the
Ed Man Dan Cummings I don't know what to
tell you man [__] love to death TR you
are small town trash man gang he's got a
brand new special out on YouTube right
now that you got to check out trying to
get better the one the only Mr Dan
cumins everybody yeah man thank you so
much thank you guys uh yeah so much I
feel like I feel like a a a like a part
of an odity
Museum glass we're just poking
you but uh it is it is interesting for
me like cuz you guys grew up a big city
right like yeah
outside yeah yeah B City bigger than 400
dude we're playing three-man
football oh man anything else you want
the folks out there to know hit them
yeah plug away social dates anything
yeah just going to be doing a big tour a
big theater tour uh next year in 2024 uh
dates of danc com.tv and then time suck
if you like deep Dives and a lot of dark
humor uh about you know true crime or
Cults or serial killers uh you know like
different things historical figures
that's time suck and then scared to
death is like campfire paranormal Tales
because I uh like to try and scare
myself my wife with stories there it's
awesome the pods are cooking
congratulations on thank you guys
congrats on your guys' success thank you
really cool it was so much fun to sit
down with you Kippy what do you got for
him guys we're all over the road as well
uh fourth show out in Chicago third show
out in Toronto get those tickets the
second show in philia selling so don't
snooze or you're going to lose gang we
love you gang we love you and we'll see
you next week peace peace